hallo mein name ist lukas meine lieben
freunde ich denke jeder von euch kennen
kugel und auf google kann man nicht nur
interessante sachen suchen nein man kann
auch mit der plattform selbst
interessante dinge anstellen wie zb hier
denn hier fällt google einfach mal ins
wasser
wenn wir jetzt irgendwas eingeben zum
beispiel luca - shop.de
wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel auf suchen
klicken kommen einfach neue fische wir
können hier ganz oft auf suchen klicken
und dann ist nachher alles hier voll mit
fischen und wenn wir auf gut glück
klicken dann kommt einfach und ganz viel
geld aber was bringt eigentlich dieses
auf gut glück bei google
und zwar mit dieser google erweiterung
und das ist eine website bei der wie
beispielsweise einfach mal den mund
hinnehmen können und auf merkel
[Musik]
dementsprechend wie weit wir den mund
aufmachen verändert sich die tonlage
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel nur ein
bisschen mache
[Musik]
haben wir so
ich kann es aber auch bei kompletten 7
oder auch ein bisschen so hin und her
warum habt ihr mein kann einfach man
abonniert machen wir allerdings weiter
mit dieser google erweiterung um zwei
cent lions wir können hier einfach mal
noch dreck klicken und ihr seht schon
relativ schnell gleich um was es hier
geht denn wir können jetzt in irgendeine
richtung unserem ausziehen und
dementsprechend zeichnet diese website
einen weg durch irgendwelche random
google maps orte wie krank ist es
virtuell dass man mittlerweile mit dem
internet anstellen kann weiter geht's
mit diesem witzigen google addon und
zwar müssen wir hier in logos von
großunternehmen aus unserem gedächtnis
zeichnen es geht los mit mcdonalds und
daher will ich einfach sagen ich mache
das so wie wir lagen ja danke die scroll
mal ein bisschen weiter runter haben als
nächstes das nike logo das würde ich so
zeichnen
ich wusste gar nicht dass er so so so
das apple logo ist das nächste das
glaube ich kriege ich relativ gut hin
als wären wir oben mir das blättchen
dann hier hier ist es ein bisschen an
gebissen und dann geht es hier gegen
diese hoben das sieht mehr aus wie eine
birne aber ihr wisst was ich meine zehn
stunden später alter überhaupt keine
ahnung ich glaube dass ihnen so ein typ
in der mitte und da ist ein kreis rom
oder so ja ich bestelle locker jede
woche irgendwas bei amazon und weiß
nicht wie das verdammte logo aussieht
ich glaube amazon hat auch von kreis und
in der mitte irgendwie seinen
einkaufswagen oder so irgendwie sowas in
die richtung dass hier müssen wir jetzt
dass pepsi logo zeichnen ich glaube die
haben doch irgendwie in seiner
geschwungenen schrift irgendwie pepsi
und das dann in unserem kreis drin oder
soja wie soll ich denn das blaue zeichen
wenn ich hier nur oder ding ist das
wetter ist easy das ist einfach dieser
vogel der sieht irgendwie so aus
snapshot ist einfach dieser geist der
ist irgendwie so also ich würde es jetzt
am liebsten hier gern so füllen aber ihr
wisst was ich meinen song nasa logica
woher soll ich das denn wissen ich würde
sagen irgendwie so und dann noch
irgendwie mit rot runter weil das dann
das feuer von der rakete darstellen
das war ganz schnell ersetzt das habe
ich jetzt noch dass spotify logo ich
habe überhaupt keine ahnung
unser podcast ist exklusiv bei spotify
ich habe keine ahnung wie es aussieht
ich hab so irgendwie bin ich werde das
so bleibt das war jetzt nicht so gut
machen allerdings weiter mit der
nächsten witzige google erweiterung und
zwar ist es das ist frage ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich hey hier ist alles
einfach nur grau was macht diese website
denn ich kann die maus jetzt einfach mal
gedrückt halten und dann rieselt es hier
sand und wenn ich aufhöre
ja ich halt auf das coole ist dass wir
überall sand hin schützen können und
dementsprechend welche ebene gerade
anvisiert wird verändert sich die farbe
ich kann die richtige berge machen ich
mache jetzt mal die alpen zweiter sind
jahre später sieht unnormal stabil aus
als erstes haben wir ein spiel das man
auf der google suchseite selbst spielen
kann und was nicht
ihr müsst einfach google snake game
eingeben dann kommt diese kleine
schlange und wir können jetzt einfach
losfahren müssen nur das ding dann ein
paar sekunden später
[Musik]
so geisteskrank gut ihr könnt ihr mal
gucken besseren heißt gott schafft und
in die kommentare
diese webseite hier finde ich extrem
spannend und zwar heißt sie einfach und
fragte jetzt wahrscheinlich erstmal hey
das heißt es englisch bedeutet verkaufen
und diese website zeigt einem quasi an
wie viel von welchem produkt aktuell
gerade pro minute verkauf 420 toyota zum
beispiel 45 mal wird minecraft pro
minute verkauft das finde ich irre weil
dieses spiel das eigentlich ja gar nicht
mehr so krass und 81 samsung fernseher
pro minute 114 airports zweimal etwa wie
dekan um was das ist dann haben wir
beispielsweise nordtirols wir haben hier
suppe wir haben iphones wir haben es nie
da wir haben pizza wir haben mcdonald's
big macs und ganz unten mit jeff dieses
und amazon pakete und da kommt das hier
denn es werden tatsächlich pro sekunde
222 amazon pakete verschickt und ich
weiß nicht mal wie das logo aussieht
das ist die nächste website
wir können makkaroni hier hinsetzen oder
beispielsweise auch eine fossile oder
viele fossilien oder eine spaghetti oder
eine spaghetti solange meine nudel bis
wir bei der länge sind brauchen jetzt
noch ca 13 jahrzehnte ich mache den
ganzen stream voll mit loriots da und
jetzt können wir theoretisch die soße
nehmen und hier einfach mal folgendes
hin schreibt wieder kommen wir nun
allerdings auch zum letzten allerdings
meiner ansicht nach auch spannendsten
und interessantesten website für heute
und zwar die pcie der name sagt es
eigentlich schon so ein bisschen und
zwar sehen wir was sich an welcher
meeres obergrenzen tiefe dings ihr wisst
was ich meine was sich dort für tiere
aufhalten haben beispielsweise hier in
den polarbären der bis zu 30 meter tief
tauchen kann wir haben hier robben
wir haben hier ein clown zwischen und
was ich am aller komischsten bzw
ekelhafteste finde ist wenn wir wirklich
ganz tief rein gehen hier runter sehen
wie eine krabbe und das ist nämlich wir
sind gleich da wir sind schon bei 650 m
diese hier das ist die japan japan is
the japanese beider crème de la crème
wurde maximum lag spurs die beide von
dieser krabbel sind vier meter
auseinander
an der stelle ich das heute wieder zu
beenden beide lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat er lasse gerne einen
daumen hoch unter mediadaten
wahrscheinlich ihr keinen gefallen
[Musik]